news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so after nominating amy coney barrett to
replace ruth bader ginsburg on the
supreme court donald trump had another
one of these rallies and you can tell
he's emboldened he's feeling powerful
he's feeling the alpha male
although remember that we can still hold
him
accountable for his perversion of
democracy and remove him
let's look at a few clips from this
event this was a rally in middletown
pennsylvania
it was truly horrifying yes donald trump
was again struggling to speak of course
we'll get those out of the way
first saying joe biden should be asking
people not for forgiveness
but for forgiveness
and all right take a listen to this you
shouldn't be asking
for your vote he should be begging for
your forgiveness
a little hokey still hope people
yeah that's not really the dystopian
part it got
truly dystopian and authoritarian very
very quickly
donald trump here commending u.s
marshals for killing a man
who was suspected of murder in portland
one eyewitness says that the man was
executed by u.s marshals note that this
doesn't include this thing what's that
thing called the right always talks
about it
uh oh due process i'm sorry yeah due
process uh it doesn't include due
process take a look
portland is anarchist and you had the
guy two weeks ago remember he shot and
killed the young man in the middle of
the street just shot him like uh
oh like i don't even say like what
because his parents
are so devastated a young man and they
shot him and killed him this one guy
this one animal
and two and a half that's right over his
hat
not our hat it was another hat it was a
christian hat it was a christian hat
he was a christian he was a christian
and they shot him
killed him instantly and this guy that
shot him everybody knew who he was
right and i said after two days where is
he did you arrest him no he didn't
after two and a half days did you arrest
him and then i put out on
social media why didn't you arrest him
and you know what
the u.s marshal saw it they went in
and he pulled a gun on him in 15 minutes
it was all over
none of our guys were hurt and he was
gone
these crowds will cheer for anything
they
they truly will then trump continuing
with
his fear-mongering about the election
thanks to mail-in ballots which trump is
simultaneously saying
will be fraudulent but at the state
level the trump campaign is telling
people
their supporters request absentee
ballots vote by mail vote by mail
notice in this one that donald trump's
fear-mongering starts to peter out like
he almost
it looks like he's running out of
batteries and he seems to realize he's
not making much sense
so he goes back to the teleprompter
which he uses despite
attacking joe biden for using one it's
actually
jarring when trump switches from riffing
aimlessly
back to the prompter and all i'm asking
is people go out to vote go out to vote
and stop with this nonsense because
we're going to be counting ballots for
the next two years
and i don't want to end up in the
supreme court and i don't want to go
back to congress either
even though we have an advantage if we
go back to congress does everyone
understand that
i think it's 26 to 22 or something
because it's counted
one vote per state so we actually have
an advantage oh they're going to be
thrilled to hear that
i'm sure they're trying to figure out
how can we break that one
biden wants to confiscate your guns and
indoctrinate your children
with poisonous anti-american lies in
schools right
donald trump does this unintentionally
hilarious thing during these speeches
where he reads the teleprompter not as
if they're his own words he reads the
teleprompter as if it's a news article
that he's commenting on
and then he'll react to it sometimes he
actually seems surprised by what's on
the teleprompter
very very odd particularly for a guy who
criticizes everybody else for using
teleprompters
then his fans start chanting lock her up
when hillary clinton's name was raised
and donald trump
says i agree lock her up
that was like hillary remember she made
a horrible statement
about clean coal and then she went
crooked hillary
and then she went three weeks later
i agree trump has now said
really everybody should be locked up
hillary should be locked up
obama and biden at one point he said 50
years in prison they should be serving
for their crimes against trump trump
still has not
enumerated what those crimes are but for
their crimes against trump i believe
james comey should be locked up it
actually sounds like
a dictator when you say anybody who
disagrees with you politically should be
locked up
trump then still having trouble with the
size of his
crowds trump claims there were 35
000 people at his rally the previous
night in virginia
there were there were reportedly 4 000
people there take a look
if tens of thousands somebody said 17 18
000
last night we had 35 000 people you saw
that in virginia
you know we're making a play for
virginia
because we have a governor in virginia
you know that facts simply do not matter
the facts don't matter about the micro
the facts don't matter about the macro
it is a culture of lies it is a culture
that does not care
what reality is coronavirus he did great
we're doing great well that's a lie
crowd size is some pathetic rally you
shouldn't even be having he says 35
000. it was really 4 000. maybe then
trump
starts talking this is almost sad if
this
weren't the president it would almost
make you kind of feel pity
trump is talking about his nobel prizes
as if he won them as opposed to being
nominated for them
by bogus right-wing european politicians
take a look
gotten seven but the fake news never
even put it on
and somebody had a show where they said
the amount of time
devoted to donald trump's
peace prize two of them zero on the
network
zero then the amount of time devoted to
something else that was
negative for somebody in the republican
party like
infinite it is so disgraceful
they're so bad trump's two nobel peace
prizes what he has no nobel peace prizes
as you might know and then trump starts
to wrap up his speech
but he kind of gets sidetracked riffing
about how he has all of these weapons at
his disposal
the likes of which no country has seen
before and he again
seems to still think that a stealth
plane
is not just invisible to radar
he still seems to think it's invisible
to the naked eye
and he pulls out that sir routine that
we've come to know so well
might and we will ensure peace
through strength you know we rebuilt our
military you saw
2.5 trillion dollars we have weapons
the i i mean just to talk about them
the likes of which no country has ever
seen before the power
the strength the the uh incredible
talent and engineering
we have weapon weapons the likes of
which no country
has ever seen before we are so far
advanced over every other country
and hope to god we never have to use
them and when i got here we were a
depleted
tired military with great people but we
were exhausted we had old jet fighters
now we have brand new f-35s that are
stealth
i asked one of the pilots how good are
these planes compared to the enemy you
say well one difference is you can't see
our planes
i said let me ask you i don't know too
much about flying that helps doesn't he
said it really helps
so you can tell you can tell that yes
the rallies have always been
whacked they've always been gong shows
but you see
an emboldened trump on the basis
of having nominated a replacement for
ruth bader ginsburg
and the probably accurate assessment in
his defense
that he is likely to get her confirmed
we've got an uphill battle ahead of us
here my friends